الاسواق الشعبيه هي رئه المدن ونبضها
الحقيقي لذلك يعتبر سوق مطرح تاريخي في
العاصمه العمانيه مسقط من ابرز معالمها
الحيويه ازقه العتيقه لا تخلو من الزوار
والسياح على مدار العامله جانب حرس الكثير
من تجار السوق العمانيين على توريد
تجارتهم ومهنهم لابنائهم حفاظا على تقاليد
السوق وتاريخه الطويل عبد الرحمن العصيمي
زار هذا السوق
وانطلاقه سلسله تقاريره من عمان
[موسيقى]
هنا سوق مطرح اكثر المواقع حيويه في
العاصمه العمانيه مسقط الذي يعود تاريخه
لاكثر من 200 عام
[موسيقى]
هذا السوق شاهد حي على الاسواق الكلاسيكيه
في المنطقه حيث تتمثل بين اسقته ومحاله
الصور الاجتماعيه والمعالم العمرانيه
للسلطنه
[موسيقى]
بضائع متنوعه هنا في سوق مطرح التاريخي
باسعار مناسبه للغايه كما نشاهد هذا الشال
من القماش الكشميري الفاخر قيمته تقريبا
عشره ريالات عماني اين يقارب 30 دولار
امريكي ايضا هناك بضائع اخرى متنوعه كما
نشاهد الهدايا التذكاريه التحف الالعاب
بالاضافه الى العطورات
واللبان العماني
[موسيقى]
جمال محمد علي يعمل في سوق مطرح منذ سنوات
ورث هذه التجاره من والده ويامل ان يستمر
ابنائه من بعده في هذا السوق حفاظا على
موروث العائله التجاريه
لما يطلعون من المدارس يكون ايام الاجازات
جديد
الاعمال المحلات التجاريه على الاسواق
التقليديه
[موسيقى]
سوق مطرح يقع في الجهه المقابله لميناء
السلطان قابوس الذي لطالم كان وجهه
الرئيسيه للقوافل التجاريه والبضائع
القادمه من الشرق والغرب ليكتسبه من هذه
الادوار اسم مطرح بمعنى المكان الذي تطرح
فيه البضائع للزوار والمتفوقين
عبدالرحمن العصيمي من العاصمه العمانيه
مسقط العربيه
[موسيقى]